Gerade wenn du mit Kindern gärtnerst, ist
es natürlich toll, Gemüse anzubauen, wo
zwischen Aussaat und Ernte gar nicht so viel
Zeit vergeht.
Deswegen stelle ich euch heute fünf Gemüse
vor, die ruckzuck erntereif sind.
Ich muss zugeben, dass ich als Erwachsener
auch oft viel zu ungeduldig bin im Garten
und deswegen immer wieder froh bin, wenn ich
schnell wachsende Gemüse anbaue, sodass dann
auch schnell eine erste Ernte ansteht.
Also Bühne frei für die fünf Raketen der
Gemüsewelt!
Sagt nicht Ich hätte euch nicht gewarnt.
Da soll mir nochmal einer behaupten, dass
Gärtnern langweilig wäre.
Also ihr seht, hier geht es hoch her im Garten!
Wenn ihr noch mehr spannende Garten-Tipps
wollt, dann abonniert den Kanal und drückt
die Glocke.
Radieschen sind mit die flottesten Kandidaten
im Gemüsegarten.
Es gibt Sorten, die schon nach einem Monat
erntereif sind, die sind absolut unkompliziert
anzubauen, also auch toll für Kinder.
Wenn du Radieschen aussäst, dann gibst du
einfach alle 3 cm ein Samenkorn in die Erde,
bedeckst das ungefähr 2 cm dick mit Erde,
hältst das ein paar Tage lang feucht und
nach drei bis fünf Tagen kannst du schon
die ersten Pflanzen sehen.
Was auch noch gut zu wissen ist, ist dass
man Radieschen rechtzeitig ernten sollte,
also sobald die ihre Radieschen Größe erreicht
haben, solltest du die ernten und essen, weil
die ziemlich schnell verholzen, wenn man die
im Beet vergisst.
Was vielleicht einige von euch überrascht,
ist, dass auch einige Möhren Sorten superschnell
eine erste Ernte abwerfen.
Meine absolute Lieblingsorte für "wenn's
mal schnell gehen muss", ist die Sorte "Gonsenheimer
Treibmöhre", die eignet sich auch sehr gut
dazu, um bevor das Sommergemüse in die Beete
wandert, nochmal eine kleine Möhren Ernte
einzufahren.
Da erntet man dann so fingerdicke Bund-Möhren,
die super, super lecker sind.
Ich habe ein Mini-Video-Kurs für euch erstellt,
als kleinen Kickstart in die neue Gartensaison,
wo ich Euch zeige, wie man einen pflegeleichten,
üppigen und super ertragreichen Gemüsegarten
anlegt und sein eigenes Gemüse anbaut.
Da könnt ihr euch gerne kostenlos für anmelden,
da entsteht auch immer eine ganz tolle Gemeinschaft,
das ist einfach vor mir für euch, um euch
noch einen besseren Start ins neue Garten-Jahr
zu ermöglichen.
Ihr könnt euch gerne hier oben anmelden,
da blende ich mal den Link ein, ansonsten
ist der Link auch unten in der Video Beschreibung.
Ich freue mich auf alle die dabei sind, das
ist immer eine super nette Gemeinschaft, die
da entsteht, also meldet euch gerne an, der
Link ist unten in der Video Beschreibung.
Salate kommen ja in den unterschiedlichsten
Farben und Formen daher und werfen auch superschnell
eine erste Ernte ab, vor allem wenn man sie
als Pflücksalat anbaut.
Ich liebe es verschiedene Sorten zu mischen
und so einen bunten Salat-Teller zusammenstellen
zu können.
Bei der Aussaat muss man bedenken, dass Salat
ein Lichtkeimer ist, das heißt man darf die
Samen nicht mit der Erde bedecken, sondern
die müssen nur oben aufliegen, dann einfach
gut angießen und die nächsten Tage gut feucht
halten, bis die ersten Pflanzen aufgehen.
Man kann alle Salat-Sorten auch als Pflücksalat
anbauen, dann erntet man sehr viel schneller,
als wenn man wartet, bis sich große Köpfe
gebildet haben.
Dafür säst du den Salat einfach dichter
aus, als wenn du Köpfe ernten möchtest und
schneidest dann, wenn der Salat so ungefähr
10 bis 15 cm hoch ist, die Blätter ungefähr
3 bis 4 cm über dem Boden ab.
So kannst du die immer wieder beernten, weil
die Salate natürlich immer wieder neu austreiben
und neue Blätter bilden und hast so eine
viel schnellere Ernte und kannst jede Pflanze
bis zu fünf Mal beernten.
Wir bauen im Winter immer die Sorte Baquieu
an, eine ganz tolle Wintersalat-Sorte, eigentlich
für Kopfsalat, die wir aber als Pflücksalat
anbauen und so den ganzen Winter über unseren
eigenen Salat ernten können, im Freiland,
also eine super tolle Sorte, kann ich nur
jedem empfehlen.
Wenn ihr wissen wollt, welche Gemüse wir
im Winter sonst noch so anbauen, dann verlinke
ich euch gerne mal meine winterliche Gartentour
hier oben, da zeige ich euch, wie unser Garten
im Winter aussieht und was wir da immer noch
anbauen.
Ein weiteres Raketen-Gemüse sind Buschbohnen,
die werfen auch ruckzuck eine erste Ernte
ab.
Es ist nur wichtig zu beachten, dass man die
erst aussäen kann, wenn es draußen frostfrei
ist.
Ich benutze Buschbohnen super gern als Lückenfüller,
vor allem in der zweiten Saisonhälfte, wenn
die Beete im Sommer nach und nach abgeerntet
werden, um auf demselben Beet vor dem Winter
noch mal eine zweite Ernte einfahren zu können.
Wichtig bei Buschbohnen ist, dass man sie
regelmäßig beerntet, weil die Pflanzen dann
A mehr produzieren und B die Bohnen richtig
schön zart und knackig sind, nicht so verholzt.
Das geht nämlich super schnell, wenn man
sich zu lange Zeit mit der Ernte lässt, dass
die Bohnen dann verholzen.
Mein Freund will jetzt hier gleich Mittagessen
machen und ich habe meinen Erntekorb abgeliefert.
Das heißt wir gehen wieder raus und reden
da weiter und räumen die Küche für ihn.
Der kann übrigens super gut kochen, habe
ich das schon mal erwähnt?
Welche Gemüse wachsen denn bei euch besonders
schnell und besonders gut?
Schreibt mir das mal unten in die Kommentare,
ich finde es immer so schön da mit euch zu
plaudern.
Ja ich weiß, ich sehe anders aus, es ist
nämlich ein neuer Tag.
Der Clip, den ich eigentlich jetzt hier einblenden
wollte, war leider komplett verschwommen,
sodass ich das jetzt noch mal neu aufnehme,
dabei hatte ich eigentlich die perfekte Überleitung!
Ich wollte euch nämlich fragen: Was ist grün
und schaut durchs Schlüsselloch?
Spionat - höhöhö, witzig, oder?
Ja, der Spionat ist das fünfte Raketen-Gemüse,
der wächst nämlich auch super, super schnell.
Und falls irgendwer von euch jetzt denkt:
"Ahh, Spinat, das schmeckt doch nicht."
Da möchte ich Euch herzlich einladen, mal
Spinat aus dem eigenen Garten zu probieren,
das ist nämlich gar kein Vergleich dazu,
wie dieser Tiefkühl-Matsch aus dem Supermarkt
schmeckt.
Spinat-Lasagne aus frischem Spinat mit Schafskäse
und Sahne ...ohhh...göttlich, sage ich euch!
Wenn ihr Spinat säen wollt, dann könnt ihr
ungefähr alle 3 bis 5 cm ein Samenkorn ablegen
und gut andrücken, mit ungefähr 2 cm Erde
bedecken, gut angießen.
Wenn ihr den Spinat etwas enger sät, dann
könnt ihr Baby-Spinat ernten, der es dann
auch noch schneller erntereif als der Große
und schmeckt noch zarter und feiner, das würde
ich euch auf jeden Fall empfehlen, wenn ihr
auf eine schnelle Ernte aus seid.
Generell ist Spinat ein super tolles Gemüse
und ich würde wirklich alle Spinat-Muffel
unter euch dazu challengen das mal auszuprobieren.
Wenn du dich noch nicht für das Bootcamp
angemeldet hast, dann macht das jetzt.
Die Anmeldung ist, wie gesagt, unten in der
Video Beschreibung, ansonsten kannst du dir
hier drüben eine Playlist zum Thema "Pflanzplan
erstellen" anschauen, falls du noch keinen
Pflanzplan hast, nehme ich dich da an die
Hand und zeige dir Schritt für Schritt, wie
das geht.
Dankeschön fürs Zuschauen bis zum nächsten
Video!
Tschüss!